il y a trois ans le professeur bel et du
cnrs de roscoff révélé sur notre antenne
que l'utilisation de certains désherbant
peut provoquer des cancers sur le long
terme
aujourd'hui il estime que les
précautions nécessaires ne sont pas
prises pour mettre en garde les
consommateurs
il a donc décidé d'aller lui même
expliqué les risques encourus en donnant
des conférences comme demain soir à
ploemeur men et nous avons été très
surpris du peu de réaction parce que
pour nous la preuve les faisons la
preuve que le glyphosate qui est
contenue dans le produit commercial qui
s'appelle le roundup provoque le
mécanisme initial donc qui va conduire
la cancérisation des cellules
il ya un risque alors on va pas attendre
quinze ou vingt ans qu'elle est cancer
on sort maintenant le laboratoire pourra
expliquer aux gens voilà il ya ça il ya
ces résultats il ya le risque
et voilà le mécanisme par lequel s'est
produit certes des arrêtés préfectoraux
ont été pris il ya un mois en bretagne
pour interdire l'usagé des désherbants
en bordure de rivières ou de fausser
mais il ne semble pas vraiment
impressionné les utilisateurs les taux
de glyphosate dans les eaux bretonnes
n'ont jamais été aussi élevés quant au
procès intenté par eau et rivières et
que choisir contre monsanto le
producteur de roundup pour publicité
mensongère
il a à nouveau été reporté pour
complément enquête alors malgré les
pressions robert bellé veut informer
directement le grand public de ces
résultats le s'est aperçu de nos
tutelles est même plutôt tendance à nous
dire de ne pas trop communiquer avec la
presse de ne pas trop les faire
connaître
donc
alors que pour nous même si on n'est pas
capable de dire aujourd'hui combien il y
aura de décès dû à ça le mécanisme de
montres on suggère de prendre des
précautions que les pouvoirs publics
semblent un peu ne serait-ce que
peut-être modifier un petit peu les
manières les tests d'homologation de ses
produits pour faire évoluer les tests
d'homologation des désherbants justement
l'équipe de robert bailey a mis au point
un test de criblage mais les
financements du ministère de
l'environnement viennent de lui être
refusé pour la troisième fois
qu'importe la devise du chercheur est
inscrite sur sa porte
[Musique]